[Musique]
les sénateurs agissent
sécurisation de la chasse le sénat créer
une mission conjointe de contrôle
le 2 novembre 2020 un jeune homme de 25
ans prénommé morgan était tué près de
son domicile par une balle perdue lors
d'une partie de chasse
ses amis ont alors créé un collectif un
jour un chasseur afin d'alerter sur les
dangers de la chasse est déposée en
septembre dernier une pétition sur le
site du sénat intitulé more violences et
abus liés à la chasse plus jamais ça
le 9 novembre 2021 face à la forte
mobilisation engendrés par la pétition
et d'autres accidents dramatiques les
commissions des affaires économiques et
des lois ont annoncé la création d'une
mission conjointe de contrôle
cette mission va entendre toutes les
parties prenantes à commencer par les
promoteurs de la pétition qui demande
l'interdiction de la chasse les
mercredis et dimanches ainsi qu'un
renforcement des règles de sécurité du
contrôle des armes de chasse et des
sanctions pénales
seront également entendus des
représentants des chasseurs et des
personnalités et administrations
compétentes
sophie primas présidente de la
commission des affaires économiques
souhaite que le sénat examine en
profondeur loin de l'émotion et de
l'agitation préélectorale la question de
la sécurité à la chasse de la
réglementation relative à la détention
d'armes de chasse et des sanctions qui
peuvent résulter d'éventuelles
infractions
françois noël buffet président de la
commission des lois rappelle que la
chasse doit être sûrs pour les non
chasseurs comme pour les chasseurs
dans un souci de compiler les bonnes
pratiques la mission va par ailleurs
mené une étude de législation comparée
des différents dispositifs qui ont fait
leurs preuves à l'étranger
pour en savoir plus consultez les
travaux de la mission de contrôle
[Musique]